what is up guys my name is Jenna welcome
to episode what is this like 18.1 okay
I'm not Michael AJ 18.5 because I have a
special plan for 18.5 it's really gonna
come out on Christmas Day that's gonna
be pretty cool but yeah so this is 18.1
and I know that I released 18 like last
night from the time I'm recording this
literally like what 15 hours ago
so yeah it's this episode's coming
pretty close to the other one but I just
wanted to fix one thing first of all
someone Twitter I'll put the the Twitter
like thing the comment like right on the
screen right now no it's WB no it's
pointed out that I'm that you know that
this wall was like behind the render
distance so you'd like there's like a
black line here even though there
shouldn't be because clearly this is
like very close to the camera and that
it you know it's like it's not properly
arranged and I thought well yeah that's
actually quite the case and that's true
you know let's solve that so I thought
that I make a little episode for you
guys hopefully without you know carving
on how to actually basically position
these walls in front of the render
distance limiter alrighty so um let's
let's jump into our render that our
render 3d class I always say render dot
3d I don't know even know why but um
render 3d and basically you'll say that
in this I in his floor method we've not
like this whole like wall stuff and
let's grab all of this card so up until
the last and Kelly bracket parentheses
whatever you want to call it so you're
copping from random random equals new
random and from that that will basically
all all over the wall code let's just
cut a control X and let's close up this
method so if you put your cursor thing
that you'll see that that is the floor
method and let's just type public void
so by making a new method just for the
wall stuff public void walls ago school
walls with no parameters we have game
game here because we actually use game
time and game door controls is alive our
nanny
anything also just leave the space in
there blank and paste all of this code
so our wall I'm sorry
now walls method now has all of our wall
code in it okay so right off the bat
we've got a problem
forward you know can't be results well
variable because it is inside this
method and we can't use it that way so
it's where to solve that is just go
public he doesn't even have to be public
it can be private private double forward
and I'm just going to call it forward
global because well you know it's it's
global for the class not just for the
specific method probably double global
we weren't actually a sign into anything
let's just go here and where we see
forward under fold literature type
forward global equals forward so we're
assigning forward so we're signing on
global to whatever forward is at the
moment and yeah and that should be fine
and let's just grab that copy and paste
that into all these ones so we're
changing forward global to forward sorry
which as you forward to forward global
so that now we we get the actual data
that we need all right I should say this
way to solve it in my opinion anyway
okay so if we run this let's just ah
actually it probably won't display okay
it's not saying I wall okay so now what
we've essentially done is it's put all
of the wall code into a into a walls
method so now let's go into our screen
class because remember the screen java
class is what actually renders this
stuff and let's just go ahead and say
render dot walls and now if we hit ctrl
else you'll say that those walls are
generating and they're actually in
france of the thing and the reason is
that the code works like this right
you've got you've got this happening
first so it's rendering the floor then
the render distance limiter and then the
wall so if we grab the walls and
actually put them in in France so
beforehand the reddit
since limiter and hit control s which I
will in a second you know it will
actually render those walls in front
hang on
it'll render sorry it'll render this
thing because it works in chronological
order right it renders this first then
this then this
so it'll render it'll render our render
distance limiter after the walls so we
don't want that so if we hit ctrl s
you'll see that they're actually you
know the walls are behind the render
distance limiter so let's just grab that
and move it after and you will say that
well as you saw before they are now in
front of the things in front of the
render distance limiter and they
actually look like they're well you know
close to the camera time okay that's the
that's how you solve that um and the
other thing is someone pointed out in
the comments as well that like having
different methods is really good because
what you can do is you can just
basically minimize the method like you
can hide it you can collapse it so that
you know this walls thing this is almost
a hundred lines of code right here and
that's heaps like we don't want that in
the way of stuff so if we just hit that
and we can sort of like it for this
minus and plus sign here we can actually
like easily select sort through our code
so we could say okay well there's three
different components being rated in the
rendered or 3d class that's floor again
I said rounded off ready in the render
3d class which is the the floor the
walls and the limiter and we if we want
to operate on the actual floor and the
rendering logic we can use that if we
just want to touch the walls we can use
walls and so on and so forth so we don't
need to say all of it at the at the one
time I'll just open that up there and
yeah so that's it that's really quick
thing I wanted to point out on how to
actually get rid of that render distance
limiter in front and yeah there we go
answering your question and I'll see you
guys later bye